émissions spéciales inédites ce soir
jusqu'à 22 heures nous allons plonger
ensemble au coeur du débat national qui
a démarré il ya à peu près un mois dans
tout le pays
[Musique]
tout de suite je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose à faire autour du grand débat on
est une chaîne de prise de parole parce
que c'est propre de l'histoire de
l'assemblée a en réalité
donc même si ça a lieu à côté c'est un
instrument de revitalisation
démocratique et on doit nous
l'accompagné
va pas sur les débats où il ya président
macro moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
précisément le fait qu'on donne la
parole aux français et pas au président
de la république puisqu'il avait déjà
allez y messieurs
oui bien bonjour à tous je voudrais vous
parler d'un problème problèmes de
pauvreté
allez-y n'ayez crainte vous êtes ému et
ben écoutez c'est pas grave que oui je
reviens sur la tva
je pensais comme madame baisser la tva
sur les produits de première nécessité
et pourquoi pas augmenté sur les
produits de luxe
je pense que dès lors que savait des
revenus en france vous devez être taxés
en france point la ligne
les français se sont approprié cette ce
moment donc il faut qu'on la compagne et
là j'ai dit on va faire une grammaire
sportive cers qu'on va faire multiplex
comme il y avait des multiplexes pour
les journées de championnat les journées
important de championnat de foot nous
serons en direct de quatre villes sur
tout le territoire et vous êtes tous
tous les quatre sur place en multiplex
bonsoir myriam saint germain laprade
commune de 3600 habitants nous sommes
donc à croix dans les départements du
nord je me trouve à la maison de la vie
associative et citoyenne dans le xviiie
arrondissement parisien venu ici à
grandchamp je vais pas vous le voyez
vient de commencer sur le thème de la
fiscalité et du pouvoir d'achat ici il
ya les organisateurs regardez vous
l'avez dit ils sont issus du mouvement
des gilet jaune mais ils n'ont pas mis
le g jo les ont tenu à le dire
ce soir ce sont d'abord des citoyens on
avait déjà en plateau qui pouvait avoir
une analyse un peu sa vente
mais en même temps on avait la
traduction si j'ose dire in situ par ce
qu'il se passait dans tel ou tel endroit
qu'on avait choisi force est de
constater qu'on n'y arrive pas on n'y
arrive pas peut-être parce que on va pas
vers les citoyens pour essayer de poser
une fiscalité qui soit un peu plus juste
et donc mieux comprises et mieux
acceptée c'est une condition même me
semble-t-il de la démocratie là on est
au coeur j'ai non seulement notre
mission mais d'un projet intéressant
c'est à dire qu'on a à la fois une
parole un carnet et la parole des
français et on a une parole
j'allais dire distancié qu'est la parole
des gens qui réfléchissent le pays qui
est qu'il analyse qu'il étudie et que ça
et je trouvais que c'était bien de les
faire se rencontrer
[Musique]